ça y est c'est fait enfin on en parlait
depuis si longtemps
l'hôpital jean minjoz de châteaufarine à
besace on a donc ouvert ses portes ce
matin
d'aucuns diront il a entrouvert ses
portes en effet depuis ce matin deux
services fonctionnent dans ce nouvel
hôpital
la médecine interne et la gastro
entérologie
si tout va bien il accueillera 300 lits
fin 84 soit 40 % de sa capacité
déménagement ailleurs ménagement enfin
l'hôpital jean minjoz jour de
châteaufarine a entrouvert ses portes
aux jours d'ouverture discrète qui
continuera dans les prochains mois tout
est affaire de moyens c'est à dire de
crédit et donc de personnel si les
promesses non tenues depuis ce matin des
deux services qui viennent d'être
ouverts sont d'une part le service de
médecine interne et d'autre part de
gastro entérologie de service qui
jusqu'àlors fonctionner à ambroise paré
et domaine nous assurons le transfert du
service de chirurgie digestive et
vasculaire qui se trouve également en
brasse paraît et qui je crois
actuellement hébergé une vingtaine de
malades qui sont donc transféré dans la
journée de demain professeur dupont vous
êtes installé depuis aujourd'hui dans
ses nouveaux locaux
alors votre première impression écoutez
j'ai l'impression total six adorables il
est vrai que nous venons d'arriver donc
il dresse à découvrir maintenant ces
structures que nos positions sur plan
mais qu'ils paraissent parfaitement
adapté à ce que peuvent exiger des
malades des soins de médecine moderne
donc sous réserve de quelques petits
problèmes d'adaptation qui devront se
faire dans l'avenir mon impression est
tout à fait favorable
et j'espère qu'elle y premiers malades
que nous avons accueilli ce matin seront
là pour le confirmer
vous explorez dans ce volet là un numéro
de téléphone pour votre famille mais
après notre famille
la première étape franchie les suivantes
sont en vue après le service de
chirurgie digestive vasculaire qui
commencera à fonctionner dès demain
priorité sera donnée au plus mal logés
de l'hôpital saint-jacques ces services
sont nombreux dans les sous sol et dans
les combles à châteaufarine la place
demande pas et les conditions de travail
seront tout haut nous pensons pouvoir
ouvrir au moins vers le mois de mars
avril le service de radiothérapie qui
fonctionne dans les conditions assez
mauvaise actuellement à saint jacques et
qui risquent tous les élèves et surtout
au printemps d'être inondées et on
aimerait bien pouvoir l'installer en
normalement de noël installé donc vers
le mois de mars et avril
mais cela suppose corrélativement
l'ouverture d'une partie du service de
la radio de la radiologie général dans
le service de radiothérapie a également
besoin
à la fin de cette année 120 lits seront
utilisés et tout au long de 1984
l'installation continuera les services
déjà en place seront complétés la
chirurgie sera mis en place avec les
blocs opératoires
si tout va bien 300 lits seront occupés
en fin d'année ils représenteront 40% de
la capacité de l'hôpital prévue pour 792
malades